we got some more abuse coming your way
everybody
in today's segment about the apocalypse
marketwatch.com says inflation has
lessons for a very entitled generation
says blackrock co-founder that's right
one of the largest largest wealth
management firms in the world their
president has come out and said the
entire generation should
what is it what did they say put on
their seat belts
to cope with scarcity inflation saying
we've never seen anything like this for
the first time this generation is going
to go into a store and not be able to
get what they want and we have a very
entitled generation that has never had
to sacrifice he's not completely wrong
just i don't think anybody wants to hear
from this guy wrong messenger and by the
way we did not plan that transition
because that was a perfect transition
it was a little stark but it was perfect
oh yeah the news is coming this is not
the person
that you want delivering this message
this guy is just absolutely i mean these
they're pillagers they're professional
pillagers that's what they do they're
pillaging our communities and they're
making life impossible for young people
we want to know why young people are
turning to socialism and communism it's
because of blackrock blackrock is what
is igniting that because they can't see
a future where they can own a home where
they can have kids credibly and be able
to say oh yeah my kid's going to have a
good life
democrats it's also democrats because
the democrats policies on like student
loans and all that yep and all what ends
up happening is you know we want student
loan forgiveness well like inflation
hits and everyone's like no i can't
afford to buy a house and so it's a
combination of this it's corporatocracy
and corporate you know corporate uh you
know some people said corporate
communism which doesn't really make
there needs to be a new word
so you're touching on the fact that that
this is something that i've noticed a
lot it's hard for us to define what this
is you know because it's sort of the
fusion of a lot of things and we need a
new word because it's really a
technocracy fused with corporatism fused
with left-wing fascism you know so
it's like
it needs its own thing its own lane that
yeah it's chaos you know essentially but
you know i think that
until we stand up to these people it's
not going to end it's insane it's toxic
technocracy when people are addictedly
using technology that they don't know
how to build no no no technocracy is a
rule by through technology they're only
ruling because the people don't have the
ability to repair their stuff and they
don't know how to build the stuff so
it's like this class of builders this
class of industrialists are
now because they have control of the
production that's why it's a technocracy
otherwise it would be like a
decentralized technological revolution
well they're almost an arm of the
government too though which is another
concerning point because if you look at
the big tech companies they're taking
orders from the democratic party you
look at every one of these tech
companies and i think tim you've
actually talked about this before you
may not remember because you talk so
much about stuff but you talked about um
how many of these big tech companies
have former staffers of the democrat
senators and democrat house members i
mean it's it's ludicrous it's literally
every single one andy stone from
facebook uh from facebook from facebook
worked for the uh barbara boxer right it
was a democratic congressional campaign
committee yeah i think he worked for
barbara boxer too well yeah there you go
and this is a guy who actively
suppressed the hunter biden news story
yep or at least announced they were yep
so these people are evil yep and look
back at the 2020 election they actually
had people uh from california's um
government going and emailing the big
tech companies sending them tweets that
they wanted taken down
okay
that is you can't get more blatant than
that the government getting involved in
deleting speech censoring speech
yeah i used to growing up i was like
well the americans are the good guys so
if we have american technocrats we'll
they'll be they'll do the right thing
but then as i got older i realized no
power just they always seems to corrupt
i think power you get insulated in your
own environment people around you start
telling you you're doing good you're
doing the right thing you don't have to
see the fallout from the choices you're
making because you're hidden from it
you're protected and then uh and then
they make utilitarian decisions because
what other choice do you have you got to
be either you make personal decisions
you're utilitarian yeah and you have to
make utilities at least you think you
have to make utilitarian decisions at
that level and you don't see the pain
more of these people in power is never
the answer i mean look at something like
student loans when
did we get an actual student loan
problem when george bush made it
impossible to declare bankruptcy on your
student loans wasn't it it's government
getting involved period
government getting involved period is
the problem government should have never
been involved they shouldn't be in the
loan business they don't know the loan
business they're terrible at it you know
if you look at the actual numbers
they're terrible at it
when there was actually a privatization
of this and you were able to have a bank
go to jenny and say hey jenny
we just don't think it's a good move to
give you 300 000 to get a gender studies
degree
that was a smart sound business decision
and it was honestly a sound decision and
a great favor they were doing to jenny
who wanted to go to gender studies
school for 300 000 or major in it you
know
when we got away from that and the
government got involved everything went
downhill or i should say uphill and
we're talking about the prices you know
but that's what happens when government
gets involved it always goes poorly like
they have some value with like fdic
insurance and things like where the
government will insure the loan to the
company if that never gets paid back is
that you think that's valuable
i mean how rare has it been that it's
actually been something that's been
useful to normal people i just think
people like bill gates
they they look around at uh
he probably watches too many videos
online of just dumb people or he goes to
like reddit uh reddit's the subreddit
idiots in cars and he just sees all of
this really awful the worst of humanity
and so then he has this view of just
like
you know he's been seeing the worst
since the 80s because he would he was
the technocrat that was watching
everyone's windows activity without them
realizing it for all through the 80s and
the 90s
he created i'm sure he was his company
that's what it's built on is it extracts
data so he's been doing that since he
built it he built in the 80s to a
certain degree he has information on you
know how people use their products and
services
just in general i was gonna have a great
understanding there's zuckerberg too is
a psychology a psychologist went to
school for psychology he's not a
psychologist he's a robot he studied it
yeah there's just so many people that
are wealthy that just have disdain for
the working class and regular people as
stupid as 100 percent
the plebeians this is like thousands of
year old and probably even before that
the romans had like an entire class of
pretty much everybody i'm just a man
we're living a story told many times
through history so there was there were
republicans in your district were uh
sitting
all sitting in their 50 000 a year club
you know drinking uh tea or wine and
smoking cigars and there's just one big
fat republican he's like i dare say this
robbie starbuck who is trying to run we
can't love the rabble in congress
and he's like call up your congressman
your state representative and get a bill
passed you forgot to mention my hair my
hair was definitely a part of that
conversation yeah you just see your hair
it's like oh sarah
and then the other guy's like i'll call
them right away
and then you got the accents wrong but
on content probably bad guys are always
british for some reason yeah i think
those are british accents ancient
ancient hatred in that see tennessee
accents just sound too nice if you did
that same thing in a tennessee accent it
would sound like a really sweet thing
they were doing but um
no um it's probably pretty similar yeah
i mean that's what happens with power
when you have you know consolidated
power like that among a group of people
they
get very protective of each other and
they'll do everything they possibly can
to stop people from shaking that power
up you know look be real though we can't
allow the rabble to be in congress
rabble could you imagine man i think
this is like it's almost scarily
realistic this conversation we're having
because okay it has happened in the past
you had the plebeians and now you have
the 99 and then so
is there must be a reason that it keeps
appearing over and over again maybe it's
by design maybe a small group of 120 iq
people decided to orchestrate society so
that they could stay on top or maybe we
just have not learned the lesson yet you
know there's that meme what does it go
like hard times create um strong strong
men strong strong men create hard times
good times good times yeah good times
great week man weak men create hard
times and it goes on
there's a lot of truth to that that's
what it is man and that's what we're
living through there's been a lot of
very very weak men for a long time who
have gotten very comfortable
sitting around with their cigars
drinking whatever they drink they have
no clue what the heck their kids are
doing their kids turn into far left
crazy people
and they're totally disconnected from
reality for normal people
and then you build a society where times
get really hard which i would actually
argue we're entering into right now i
think people are going to really start
to feel the effects of
what these people have done to our world
over the past couple of decades and
2026. we're going to have some very
strong men rise out of it that are going
to have to bring us out and aren't going
to have to do hard things
2026 so many people have told me that's
that's the year and i'm like what does
that mean that surprises me well it's uh
there's a couple different you know
analyses there's mit's data on you know
they calculated 40 years ago when it was
all gonna hit the fan there's some other
guy who gave an interview device like 10
years ago as an expert on the stuff said
it's all gonna hit the fan in the early
2020s and then you have strass out
generational theory which predicts we're
entering the final season of tumult and
but however
did they include joe biden in their
calculations
because it may be coming sooner
pre-civil war buchanan yeah we we had a
feckless pathetic president then and
many people have said joe biden seems to
be our buchanan which is going to lead
us into this this tumultuous period look
if donald trump wins in 2024 do you
think the left is going to be like well
you know donald trump won fair and
square so
definitely nope oh my gosh that'd be
great absolutely not yeah and the civil
war that we're headed towards now is
going to be like the metaverse versus
base reality and like yeah well that's
not for sub humans yeah
we've got a little time before we get
there i think we're going to have an
actual physical experience that people
are going to live through something
that they're going to say this used to
be things we only read about and this is
reality now and i'd say this has been a
long-term problem for our country that
our young people have been largely
disconnected from the experiences of the
world and it's a picture on a screen not
a reality not a physical thing that you
can understand and so if they see the
experiences of somebody in let's say
africa
it's just a photo it's just an image you
can't feel it you can't taste it you
can't touch it you don't know what that
world is actually like and i think when
they go through the hard times that we
may be facing unless some really drastic
things happen
it's gonna it's gonna change things it's
gonna change everything and even down to
relationship levels of what people want
out of their partners and what people
want out of their life in general and
you're gonna see so much change it's
going to make this great migration look
like nothing this thing that's happened
where everybody's moved all over the
country it's going to make that look
like nothing because you're going to see
changes that are just flipped on their
head in every segment of society thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there